[Musique]
bonsoir audition publique notre rendez
vous du lundi soir une heure en direct
sur lcp assemblée nationale public sénat
et le figaro live une heure pour faire
le tour de tous les débats du moment les
sujets qui fâchent aussi parfois
alors évidemment il va être question
aujourd'hui des retraites de
l'agriculture des élections municipales
également avec notre invité qui est
julien bayou bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts
vous venez d'accéder à ce poste il ya
une semaine que tu as bien grande
interview merci de nous l'avoir accordés
et vont venir à tour de rôle sur ce
plateau mes consoeurs des chaînes
parlementaires pour vous poser toutes
les questions d'actualité du moment
puis deux parlementaires une député un
sénateur qui débattront avec vous avant
qu'il thréard du figaro ne vienne
conclure l'émission est allé beaucoup
plus loin aussi
sans oublier évidemment les questions
que les téléspectateurs peuvent nous
faire parvenir sur figaro live qui
arriveront ici et que je relaierai au
fur et à mesure dans la mesure du
possible
une première question d'abord jean luc
mélenchon condamné aujourd'hui à trois
mois de prison avec sursis 8000 euros
damende après la perquisition
mouvementée au siège de la france a
soumis en octobre 2018 sur la lal
enquête sur le financement de la
présidentielle il a été condamné pour
rébellion et provocations jean luc
mélenchon continue de dénoncer un procès
politique
est ce que vous faites la même analyse
non non je pense pas à ça et c'est
difficile de commenter une décision de
justice de dire que ces politiques dans
ce cas là il faudrait assumer aussi que
la mise en examen de françois bayroux
elle est politique et la condamnation
assez ferme de balkany est les
politiques aussi et ça n'est pas bon
au fait il ya ce dicton qui dit la
justice est aveugle c'est-à-dire
qu'elles frappent de manière
indifférente que vous soyez pauvre ou
puissant
je crois qu'il faut plutôt s'en réjouir
en fait je n'ai pas de animosité
particulière à l'égard de jean luc
mélenchon bien au contraire je pense que
si n'importe qui se retrouvaient à
violenter ou être accusé de violenter un
magistrat un policier la sanction serait
sévère donc je vais pas me prononcer sa
savoir si le jugement est sévère ou pas
de là à dire que c'est politique
nous gérons pas sur ce stade on va
parler maintenant même je me réjouis en
vrai pas qu'il soit condamné bien sûr
mais que notre pays soit capable de
juger ces responsables politiques c'est
même le signe d'une démocratie est assez
mature
j'attends les gisements de différents
responsables politiques sur sur quoi par
exemple sur les affaires nicolas sarkozy
par exemple dénoncé par mediapart
la justice doit passer il est aussi
l'avocat pour les blanchir ou pour les
condamnés mais l'heure l'idée de
françois bayrou à propos de les
assistants parlementaires européens
vous savez que yannick jadot était sur
la liste de sophie montel la députée
front national vous craignez pas que ça
vous rattrape un jour ben nous on est
très très sérieux avec ses affaires de
vous n'avez pas de crainte à dessus nos
assistants parlementaires travaillent
oui pour l'europe il peut y avoir une
mise en examen une enquête ça vous le
craignez rien que les enquêtes se fasse
comme on ne demande pas un traitement
particulier sur cette affaire donc de ce
film ont-elles donc une eurodéputée ex
eurodéputé fn qui en gros pour faire
diversion des accusations vis-à-vis du
rassemblement national porté par le
parlement européen
c'est pas des accusations en l'air c'est
des demandes de sommes colossales qui
doivent être remboursés par le
rassemblement national
elle a un peu comme ça j'étais au
bazooka pour accuser tout tout le monde
nous on est relativement serein
tranquille que la justice s'intéresse
aux activités assistant parlementaire et
a priori trouvant rien mais voyez marine
le pen parle d'éthique et refuse de se
rendre devant le juge bien on va parler
de la version d'un autre sujet qui
concerne beaucoup de gens puissent y
avait beaucoup de monde dans les rues
la semaine dernière contre la réforme
des retraites et pour en parler avec
vous tam tran huy
de public sénat et brigitte bouger de la
chaîne parlementaire assemblée nationale
arrive sur ce plateau en face de vous
[Musique]
brigitte bonsoir une brigitte vous
commencez oui avec jean paul delevoye
jean paul delevoye qui a démissionné
aujourd'hui de son poste de l'institut
de la formation de la profession de
l'assurance pour éviter tout conflit
d'intérêts est ce que ça suffit pour
vous c'est
j'ai pas comment dire ça fait tâche
c'est gênant le rapport a déjà été remis
et voilà jean paul delevoye a des liens
avec l'assurance or un des reproches
qu'on fait à cette réforme c'est de
manière indirecte de pousser à la
capitalisation
en gros on vous dit cette gaffe votre
réforme va pas vraiment être assurée
votre retraite va pas vraiment être
assurés ou peut-être on s'assure des
points et le point va baisser donc il
vaut mieux faire ceinture et bretelles
et capitalisées par ailleurs gagnant
plus que les riches peuvent faire mal et
on est donc bien sûr que d'ailleurs
c'était dans le parisien un des
responsables d'une grande assurance qui
disent oui on a intérêt à la réforme
donc que vous ayez un problème ya
conflit d'intérêt ou un conflit
d'intérêts mais il doit démissionner de
son poste comme c'est malheureusement le
rapport a été remis
donc je pense que il ya beaucoup à
redire sur ce rapport
oui c'est sûr va continuer à porter le
simple fait d'avoir démissionné ne règle
pas les craintes et la meilleure
solution c'est que le gouvernement fasse
enfin la transparence sur ces
propositions ça va venir mais c'est quoi
ce pays où au bout de deux ans et demi
de mandat on est encore à s'interroger
sur byron encalade berling en question
table oui vous étiez dans la rue le 5
décembre vous tenait d'ailleurs à peu
près ce discours lors de la
manifestation
est ce que vous y serez demain à ce que
vous appelez à continuer à manifester
moi je n'y serai pas personnellement
mais nous serons les écologistes
présents dans les manifestations demain
absolument et on attend avec impatience
les propositions d'edouard philippe
j'insiste là dessus c'est pas sans un
pays qui pendant deux ans et demi vit
sous tension sans savoir à 10 ou 15 ans
et cette association c'est la
concertation vous dit le gouvernement
n'aurait j'adorerais sauf que pendant
deux ans il ya une concertation même la
cgt par exemple qui est plutôt critique
à l'égard de le voir a dit très bien au
moins on a discuté et delhommeau le
rapport remis le rapport est déchiré m
delevoye et contredit et on repart sur
un débat et qu'est ce qu'a dit le
gouvernement on a essayé d'enjamber des
municipales eh bien ça veut dire que
vous enfoncez la montre mais vous
traiter un sujet aussi crucial que ça
qui concerne littéralement 100% des
salariés de manière opportuniste et
électoralistes alors il ya la date du 10
décembre
demain il ya une autre date le 11
décembre le lendemain rassemblement de
toute la gauche contre les retraites ce
projet de réforme des retraites
finalement est-ce que ce ce ce mot
d'ordre là il sera pas compliqué étant
donné que vous avez tous des positions
différentes sur l'avenir des retraites
qu'est-ce qui peut en sortir je vivais à
saint-denis à l'invitation du parti
communiste pour exposer la position des
écologistes
nous on est attaché au système de
répartition et on considère pas qu'il
faut le laisser tel quel
parce que il est à améliorer sur bien
des points la prise en compte des
carrières notamment des femmes des plus
précaires et ainsi de suite
on est vigilant sur cet aspect de
capitalisation parce que si c'est pour
aller sur des points et qu'ensuite on
puisse vous le bc et ben en fait tout ça
ça vous obscurcit l'horizon et déjà que
le gouvernement s'est pas assez sur la
transition écolo ce qui nous ferme
l'horizon tout simplement vis-à-vis du
dérèglement climatique
là il s'agit d'accentuer la précarité
vraiment le pour les plus vulnérables
jusqu'à la fin est-ce que vous ne
voterez dans l'effort mais moi je ne
sais pas quelle est la réforme
alors justement arrivé c'est quand même
un sujet c'est quand même un sujet si un
système par points avec avec prestations
définies
c'est ça qui est quand même en jeu si
vous avez cotisé est-ce que vous saurez
si vous avez droit à 1200 tout du long
ou en fait plutôt 1000 1050 julien bayou
aussi ça dépend de la croissance est
allé avec travail sur sur les détails
justement vous n'en avez pas parlé est
ce que vous défendez les quarante deux
régimes spéciaux de retraite à ce que
vous demandez à ce qu'ils se poursuivent
ben moi je dis que égalité vos par
l'uniformité qu'il faut pouvoir prendre
en compte des situations différentes et
que en tout cas ceux qui ont se sont
installés défendra ce régime en
connaissance de cause avec un package
global ces liens en gros les cheminots
pour les nommer qu'ont décidé de
démarrer dans cette carrière avec toutes
les contraintes que ça ils se lèvent tôt
pour qu'on ait des trains pour le boulot
on le voit aujourd'hui quand y'en a pas
c'est plus compliqué ils ont des
astreintes d'aidé familiale plus
compliqué donc ils doivent garder ils
ont ils ont ce régime spécial ça tout va
bien mais s'il y avait la cause du grand
père pour les moteurs en tout cas je
conçois le déchirer en cours d'eau où tu
n'avais pas les moyens entre les
nouveaux on peut en discuter mais c'est
pas c'est pas forcément sujet m mais
parce qu'il me semble compliqué c'est
que ce gouvernement fait comme s'il n'y
avait pas de pénibilité
si on vous dit harmoniser ou uniformisé
moi je dis non parce qu'en vrai dans mes
métiers j'ai fait des métiers beaucoup
moins pénible que le fait de porter des
charges d'être exposés au bruit et donc
j'ai pas vu dans les orientations de ce
gouvernement
le fait de prendre en compte la
pénibilité et même quelque chose de plus
choquant par manger les buissons mais
emmanuel macron qui dit j'aime pas le
mot pénibilité parce que cela
sous-entendrait qu'il ya des travaux
pénibles
d'où tu sors mais bien sûr que des
travaux plus pénible que d'autres et
donc bien sûr qu'il faut prendre en
compte alors si on uniformise mais qu'on
redonne des poings par exemple comme on
redonne des trimestres aux métiers les
plus pénibles et que l'on re donnerait
des points aux métiers les plus pénibles
par exemple pourquoi pas
c'est à part aux discussions j'ai bien
gêné à noter que sur les nouveaux
entrants dans les régimes spéciaux
vous dites on peut faire une exception
et dire ceux là n'auront plus droit aux
régimes spéciaux nous notre objectif
mais c'est ça cet héritage du conseil
national de la résistance
on y tient on y attacher d'accord mais
les réformes qu'ils peuvent et justement
on est plus en 45 parce que pendant les
trente glorieuses
toute cette protection sociale elle
s'est faite sur en gros pour instruire
attendez attendez l'hectare yann en mai
la raison les carrières longues et les
cdi aujourd'hui je vous apprends rien
c'est plus la norme d'entrer sur le
marché du travail
donc oui il faut adapter notre île de
retraite abandonné aux régimes spéciaux
pour les nouveaux entrants pas forcément
enfin ce que je veux dire c'est que pas
clair moi je vous dis que samantha ça me
semble problématique de déchirer un
contrat en cours de route d'accord mais
se passerait il vous a répondu je vais
vous répondre non non c'est pas clair
vous ne dites pas vous dit est ce que
vous dites comme un gouvernement
est ce que vous dites que comme le
gouvernement on peut revoir les nouveaux
entrants venir le problème c'est que
pour ce gouvernement et ce que l'enjeu
c'est de faire une réforme
si vous faisiez s'est plaint fait
j'aimerais j'aimerais répondre parce que
justement j'ai pas envie de répondre là
dessus il se tient claire attendait
comme si c'était un totem ou un tabou
moi je vous réponds les régimes spéciaux
en vrai je m'en moque
ce que je veux c'est que les personnes
qui cotisent et droit à une protection
sociale juste accords équilibrés lé
signe que tout en versant social dans
des attentats
et donc s'il y avait un régime général
mais que par exemple on prenait d'une
manière ou d'une autre la pénibilité en
compte par exemple en donnant plus de
points je pense notamment aux femmes de
ménage qui se lève super d'eau qui
arrive en difficultés qu'ont des
horaires pas possible arrêter autres ça
c'est absolument pas pris en compte
nulle part si on invente un régime qui
prend en compte ses effets de pénibilité
le bruit les charges lourdes dont ses
systèmes universels en gros mais avec
des salles veut pas dire uniformité et
donc moi j'ai bien réelle mais j'ai pas
envie de céder à votre injonction reste
ici parce que régime spécial ou pas le
problème c'est qu'on rate l'essentiel la
pénibilité et l'autre aspect dont
personne ne parle c'est que les
personnes à 55 ans elles sont qu'à
moitié en dans l'emploi il y en a pour
l'autre moitié qui sont dans la validité
ou au chômage et toute réforme qui passa
à côté est vouée à l'échec
très fort puis travaillé comme
enseignant a crié on voit bien que c'est
eugène pour une partie des français
quelle autre aide concerne une bonne
partie des personnes injustement vous
qui êtes attachés à la démocratie
participative
est-ce que vous iriez jusqu'à dire
qu'ils font un référendum mais sur quoi
système de retraite un système par
points
mais enfin je comprends pas écoutez il
ya eu deux ans de concertation s'est
déchiré juste après après le goût de
macron apparemment pour s'en sortir tour
de passe-passe dit grande concertation
on l'a pas vu ça semblait un une astuce
pour enjamber les municipales finalement
et c'est quoi ce pays où il faut une
mobilisation massive comme celle du 5
pour qu'enfin le gouvernement dise ah
oui c'est vrai on va peut-être vous dire
ce qu'on a en tête
oui on a une démocratie qui est en fait
assez assez assez puéril en fait dont
vous me dites référendum
mais sur quoi référendum sur un régime à
points moi je vous réponds c'est quoi la
prise en compte de la pénibilité mais
oui mais c'est pas gentil et je vais la
savait quoi et je vais même le répéter
au gardien un mot sur peut-être un
acquis qui va sortir de cette situation
de blocage les automobilistes en
covoiturage sont autorisés à circuler
sur les voies de bus et de taxis sur les
grands axes qui arrive à paris c'est à
dire sur les autoroutes
est ce que c'est une bonne chose c'est
ce que cela devrait être généralisé pour
vous nous les écologistes notamment avec
la région car en charge des transports
on réclame notamment la d'insister sur
le covoiturage ou même la gratuité des
transports en commun pendant les pics de
pollution et on nous répond c'est pas
possible c'est trop compliqué mais la
salle c'est possible bon et bien donc ça
veut dire qu'on peut agir et favoriser
le covoiturage même quand y'a pas grève
et moi j'aimerais qu'on agit sur
l'écologie même quand il ya pas qu une
dernière question sur extinction
rébellion qui revendique avoir mis hors
service 3600 trottinette briseuse de
grève dit il est ce que vous les
soutenez
ouais j'ai pas vraiment suivi briseuse
de rêves le jeu serait pas vraiment vous
réponde aux intérêts la désobéissance à
la désobéissance civile pour nous c'est
pas forcément un donc c'est pacifique
il faut absolument aucune violence aux
personnes lassées de la violence
audiences plutôt du sabotage que les
débits sont civile tient donc c'est
moins gras et soutenait un où c'est
moins grave
non c'est
dix ans il déshonore civile c'est
important détruire des trottinettes
c'est pas grave
bah c'est pas de l'atteinte aux biens
mais ne dirais pas qu'on les soutient en
on va parler maintenant de la loi sur
l'économie circulaire qui est en débat
en ce moment là à l'assemblée nationale
tap
oui avec d'abord les consignes tout à
fait c'est la mesure emblématique de ce
projet de loi anti gaspillage et qui
fait le plus débat la consigne pour les
bouteilles en plastique à ce que pour
vous c'est une bonne mesure écologique
mais nous on est pour le retour de la
consigne sur le vert oui et sur le
plastique et sur le plastique ça dépend
parce que l'enjeu c'est réduire le
plastique et donc 6 et recyclés pour
pouvoir continuer à autant utiliser on a
un problème et donc tout l'enjeu c'est
est ce qu'on est en mesure de réduire
drastiquement l'usagé du plastique le
suremballage les gobelets plastique à
usage unique
il ya une donc c'est une fausse mesures
écologiques pour vous c'est pas une
bonne mesure que ça va déculpabiliser
les personnes qui utilisent des
bouteilles en plastique alors nous on
n'est certainement pas pour culpabiliser
voyez parce que quand il ya du
suremballage
quand on vous vend des bananes qui sont
emballés le plastique c'est de votre
faute vous et moi consommateur aux
consommatrices si on n'a que ça ou c'est
de la faute de ce gouvernement et de ses
édifices et m ils sont dépendants dans
l'emballage espionner donc non mais
c'est très important dans la logique du
gouvernement
il ya toujours une logique de
culpabiliser et en huile de palme c'est
pas bon pour la santé mais également
pour la déforestation est ce que c'est à
nous nos gueules et nos gamins parce
qu'ils sont dépendants à l'huile de
palme et nutella pour pas les nommer ou
est-ce que c'est au gouvernement
d'assumer d'infléchir avec cette
déforestation ces voiliers qu'à une
logique de culpabiliser les loyers
sociaux pose vraiment problème qui est
je trouve que de la part du gouvernement
c'est trop facile et ça permet de faire
diversion sur leurs propres
responsabilités suite d'une question qui
se pose c'est comment est-ce que c'est
faire un cadeau aux industriels que de
faire 7,7 consignes je pense à un coquin
danone qui pourrait gérer en fait le
recyclage est retiré un bénéfice de tout
ça mais on sait qu'aujourd'hui les
communes ont besoin de ces recettes
il s'agit il s'agit pas de les
transférer
aux industrielles l'enjeu c'est de
réduire en fait tout simplement c'est
que d'ailleurs c'est zéro waste qui est
une association reconnue en la matière
qui dit d'abord réduisant le recyclage
n'est pas une réponse une panacée
c'est parce que c'est vous recyclez que
ce que vous avez en trop finalement
l'enjeu c'est de réduire réduire réduire
réduire donc vous comprenez les
inquiétudes des mères vous avez commencé
à parler des communes qui ont beaucoup
investi dans le recyclage qui en retire
une manne financière et qui voient ce
nouveau système arrivé bien soignées à
sion et les communes sont en tension
inquiète et vous avez rien c'est très
sensuel
tout ça c'est assez brouillon en fait ce
que l'a finalement dans les débats au
parlement
c'était la mesure phare de la consigne
puis ça a été supprimé puis maintenant
on s'oriente vers une expérimentation
quand est-ce qu'on agit très
concrètement en fait on ne sait pas lire
l'ambition écolo du gouvernement ou
plutôt on sait trop bien la lire tant
que ça gêne pas alors ça va l'ambition
est peut être mondial aussi bien en ce
moment la coop 25 à madrid tam et on se
demande à quoi ça sert
oui effectivement à quoi ça sert à la
coop quand on voit qu'il ya aucun
engagement de réduction des gaz à
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qu'il a réellement été tenues depuis eh
bien la coop 21 et les accords de paris
les accords de paris doivent entrer en
vigueur prochainement l'enjeu de la coop
c'était vous le disiez d'obtenir des
engagements était un engagement
supérieur et la france et l'europe ont
failli sur ce point là donc nous tout
l'enjeu c'est de de dire qu' il faut pas
attendre des autres la france doit faire
sa part et manon vous voyez je parlais
de l'huile de palme
on nous dit c'est très compliqué trouver
des centaines de millions pour les
hôpitaux ou pour lutter contre les
féminicides mais quand il s'agit de
lâcher des impôts des cadeaux fiscaux à
total pour la raffinerie de la mède pour
un avantage fiscal sur les biocarburants
pour en gros accentuer la déforestation
à porter et bien là y'a aucun problème
pour trouver les 70 à 80 millions
nécessaires et donc ce gouvernement
n'est pas écologiste et donc on ne peut
pas c'est malheureusement ce s'étonner
qu'ils soient pas un moteur au sein de
l'union européenne pour que l'europe
accentue ses engagements oui et pourtant
il y aurait tellement à gagner on voit
le succès de greta
mr par exemple cette jeune fille qui
défend l'écologie à travers le monde
finalement est-ce que c'est pas votre
échec ce succès de cette de cette jeune
femme et ce qu'elle fait pas plus bouger
les choses que tous les dirigeants que
tous les partis écologistes
c'est marrant que vous opposiez les deux
mois je me réjouis de faire finalement
mais moi je me remets enfin je sais
vraiment une lecture journalistique
parce que moi je me réjouis j'étais
jours ça tombe bien oui mais moi je me
réjouis de son de sa capacité
d'entraînement notamment auprès de la
jeunesse mais même bien plus largement
et vous savez elle dit elle dit les
faits elle dit finalement elle vulgarise
on peut le dire comme ça
les rapports scientifiques du giec et
elle dit sa vérité
assez assez génération à c'est à ces
personnes de pouvoir qui n'agissent pas
et qui menace l'avenir des générations
attendait c'est un peu la nature en
ville c'est pas des générations et des
générations futures qui sont en fait les
générations présentes
donc bien sûr que non c'est pas une
concurrente aulas évidemment mais moi
j'appelle tous ceux qui la critiquent à
écouter ce sont les faits et si ça
dérange c'est peut-être parce que c'est
ça c'est la vérité scientifique à propos
de coop il ya eu la coop 21 à paris en
ségolène royal était l'une des actrices
elle est accusée aujourd'hui de ne pas
assez s'investir dans sa mission
d'ambassadrice pour l'épauler d'utiliser
certains de ses moyens pour faire autre
chose est ce que elle elle dit que c'est
pas vrai qu'elle est très investie
est-ce que vous la croyez
je m'en moque j'ai été très surpris
parce les accusations qu'il a portées à
l'égard de la cellule si je ne me trompe
pas c'était la cellule investigation de
radio france radio france qui fait un
travail qui dérange c'est son rôle jean
la liste d'investigation et je trouve
que les réponses qu'elle a apportée moi
je ne connais pas le dossier
mais les réponses qu'elle a apportée en
disant que je crois qu'ils étaient les
questions diffamatoires sont absolument
lunaire est complètement irresponsable
de la part de quelqu'un qui prétend
diriger le pays donc moi je ne connais
pas ces éléments de réponse at-elle été
à ces réunions
avait-elle de bonnes excuses at-elle
fait les choses ou pas je trouve que la
manière dont elle a tenté d'esquiver le
débat mérite pas responsables j'attends
pas des réponses parce que je ne compte
pas sur ségolène royal pour con
n'agissent contre le dérèglement
climatique puisque malheureusement vous
l'avez dit elle a été par deux fois
ministre de l'environnement et ça n'est
pas ça qui a particulièrement changé la
donne
mais j'aimerais vous dire un mot il
s'agit pas d' agir sur le dérèglement
climatique pour faire plaisir à greta
tanberg ou faire plaisir aux écolos
c'est une source de d'emploi colossal et
si je parle des seniors et je le vis que
j'y reviendrai qui sont pour la moitié
sans emploi quand est ce qu'on met enfin
en place les moyens pour agir sur la
rénovation thermique sur l'agriculture
bio vire-vire vous savez sur les
énergies batteur levante parce qu'il
n'ya plus d'emploi
bien oui mais c'est des parlementaires
qui font rien mais lyon me poser des
questions tu es mon fils va sur les ogm
par brigitte assurland
l'agencé nationale pour la sécurité
sanitaire alimentaire qui vient
d'annoncer l'interdiction de la moitié
des produits qui contiennent du
glyphosate est ce que vous dites bon là
c'est une bonne chose c'est une énorme
victoire énorme victoire
est ce qu'on la doit à l influence des
manuels maquereau en europe non
notamment sur le glyphosate il a porté
ce sujet là à mossel non on la doit à
une décision de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne du 1er octobre qui a
qui était interrogé par le tribunal de
foix s'ils voulaient tout savoir
question préjudicielle pour savoir si le
règlement qui autorise les pesticides
était valable
la réponse est oui et la cour de justice
va plus loin et dit par contre la
manière dont certains pays autorisent
les pesticides sont pas valables
on prend pas en compte les effets
cocktails savait que le principe le
principe majeur et puis comment les
mélanges on prend pas en compte la
toxicité à long terme et on prend pas en
compte la protection des riverains et
c'est pour ça qu'on a eu ses nerfs en
type ces mères anti pesticides qui
prenaient des arrêtés pour protéger les
riverains là du coup la ss a constaté
qu'effectivement ça faisait une bonne
dizaine d'années depuis 2013 en fait
qu'ils autorisent sans être
véritablement raccord avec le règlement
sur les pesticides et donc il en tire
les conclusions
ça fait combien de temps qu'on le dit
que ces pesticides doivent être
interdits enfin on en tire des
conclusions principe de précaution pour
protéger la population comme une
question sur les plans d'ajustement à la
distance d'épandage de pesticides par
rapport aux habitations va être annoncé
d'ici à la fin du mois on va on est
entre 3 5 et 10 mètres de distance
est-ce que ça ce sont des premiers pas
du gouvernent
ce que vous la reconnaissez s'annonce
est en recul puisque 3 5 ou 10 mètres
c'est ce qu'a écrit sur les paquets sur
les emballages
donc c'est les autorisations de mise sur
le marché de l'âne c'est ce qu'ils
prévoyaient déjà cette distance il faut
s'avancer du gouvernement ça n'est pas
une avancée
encore une fois là c'est le conseil
d'état qui les a sanctionnés en juin et
qui leur a dit votre décret n'est pas
suffisamment protecteur des riverains on
parle des riverains c'est à dire ceux
qui habite pas loin des épandages
on est sur un risque de santé publique
du type chlordécone ou amiante et ce que
nous voulons vraiment attendre 20 ans 30
ans qu'on nous dise on aurait dû prendre
des précautions
nous disons protégeons la santé des
riverains et travaillant avec les
agriculteurs pour qu'ils puissent se
passer des pesticides bien brigitte une
dernière question de petites questions
rapides vous avez vous été quelque chose
de l'olympique qui auront lieu à paris
en 2024
airbnb sera un gros sponsor est ce que
ça vous choque mais moi ce qui me choque
c'est que airbnb contribuer au
renchérissement des loyers à paris et
dans beaucoup de villes en france qu' on
n'est pas suffisamment outillée au
niveau local les merile demande pour
pouvoir en gros distinguer entre la
personne qui loue son appart parce
qu'elle n'est pas là pendant dix jours
et puis la personne qui achète un
appartement vous posez la question très
clairement qu'il n'est pas du tout celle
là mais est ce que ça vous choque que ce
soit le sponsor des jeux olympiques à
paris de 2024 ben écoutez là - l'enjeu
c'est vraiment d'encadrer airbnb séoul
et non seulement ou pas c'est un souci
c'est comme si vous faisiez total
m'allonger c'est donc avec total donc
après qu'ils se fassent leur pub
derrière c'est problématique
mais l'enjeu majeur d'accord c'est
d'encadrer airbnb est vraiment c'est
catastrophique pour toutes les personnes
qui veulent habiter dans les grandes
villes et qui sont chassés par la
spéculation terrain dernière question
pour conclure obscures à demain une
décision sur la reprise de l'activité de
l'usiné lubrizol est ce que à rouen
effectivement aux trois mois après
l'incendié du mois de septembre
l'entreprise doit-elle reprendre son
activité pour vous au moins
partiellement le monde économique
normand le demandent et d'initiation des
milliers d'emplois ces 400 emplois
l'usiné grisolles nous demandons
que cette décision soit reporté une
pétition est lancée je vous invite à la
soutenir on peut pas faire comme si rien
ne s'était passé et on a des enquêtes à
mener sur les responsabilités
le préfet avait autorisé l'extension de
lubrizol
on sait que lubrizol à stocker des
produits toxiques chez son voisin
normandie logistique c'est pas normal
c'est jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient
clarification de toute la chaîne de
responsabilités mais évidemment sinon
sinon ça veut dire que rien ne s'est
passé et on a un millier d'autres sites
seveso l'an le gouvernement doit être
mobilisé pour les inspecter c'est à dire
qu'on fasse pas courir à d'autres
populations car au rang des risques
similaires
merci tu avais brigitte savoir poser vos
questions à julien bayou parce que les
parlementaires qui ne font rien ils vous
attendent de pied ferme et ils vont
arriver sur le plateau un petit peu
appuyé merci tu avais brigitte
[Musique]
vous avez dit qu'ils ne font rien sur la
transition écologique dont on va voir
bonsoir jean bizet vous êtes sénateur
les républicains de la manche et bonsoir
bénédicte pérol vous êtes député la
république en marche de l'allier et
vice-présidente du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale on va commencer par vous
première question à julien bayou lors de
votre discours du congrès à l'occasion
duquel vous avez été désigné vous avez
dit que l'écologie était là pour pas
donner des leçons mais proposer des
solutions
vous avez aussi parlé de rassemblement
mais un peu plus tard dans le discours
vous dites aussi dans le cadre des
municipales qu'il y a des adeptes de la
contrefaçon qu' il faudrait pour qu'il
vous copie finalement comment la
question j'aimerais vous poser ce soir
c'est quelle est cette écologie de
rassemblement dont vous parlez et puis
puisque vous nous avez titiller et que
les députés ne savons rien oui oui alors
plus que la wii dans mondialement vous
allez vous en portant secours j'évoque
ces écologistes mais et puis les
écologistes pointent alors ceux qui
disent bon bah il ya toujours une bonne
raison d'attendre avant de faire de
l'écologie c'est les écologistes mais
mais mais mais peut-être qu'on va quand
même continuer à filer du fric à total
pour qu'il fasse de la déforestation à
porter et puis à les écologistes points
c'est ce qu'ils disent
l'écologie c'est la priorité
environnement justice sociale la
démocratie et donc quand je dis copier
nous parce que nous on est pour que ces
idées infuse
on dit qu'au pied nous bien aller
jusqu'au bout et donc quand on vous dit
la transition écolo c'est la rénovation
thermique
c'est faire en sorte que on rénove
vraiment les logements que ça peut créer
un emploi tous les cinq à six logements
rénovés que sa lutte contre les
particules fines
mettez du fric là dessus qu'est ce que
ça veut dire de dépenser 20 milliards
par an sans contrepartie ni sociale ni
environnementale et vous en maîtrisez la
moitié sur la rénovation thermique on le
nombre d'emplois que ça crée et les et
les gens pourrait chauffer correctement
et vous serez gagnant
je souhaitais vous dire parce que j'ai
dit à binic pérol à qui elle avait une
deuxième question j'aimerais vous poser
une question et j'ai mal j'ai une
question paraîtront à bord je ne
comprends pas moi j'ai une question
par exemple il ya des trucs maintenant
l'écologiste et a plus besoin d'être
courageux
et vous avez 80% de la population qui
est pour
par exemple sur la condition animale en
finir avec le broyage des poussins mâles
c'est un amendement qui a été proposée
par votre majorité d'ailleurs je crois
tout le monde est pour
on arrête on file les moyens aux
éleveurs de se passer de cette pratique
cruelle on broie les poussins mâles
pourquoi voulez pas voter
je comprends pas vous vous auriez vous
seriez fait aller la question mais
pourquoi c'est quoi la pluie après vous
creuser la question à ma première
question portait plus sur le local et je
vois dans ma circonscription je suis
député de l'allier donc un département
extrêmement rural où toutes les
questions de mobilité c'est une terre
d'élevage également en conservant
l'agriculture il faut amener déjà il
faut convaincre les agriculteurs etc et
d'identifier avec eux quelles sont les
solutions
et pour vous répondre sans en dire plus
précisément et sur la méthode et surtout
qu'à la philosophie qui est celle de la
république en marché et surtout qui est
la mienne dans l'application finalement
dans le concret dans le quotidien des
français de la transition écologique et
l'or en particulier de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'accompagner
les agriculteurs alors du point a au
point b on parle tout le temps du pont
des néons membres lui ce que moi me
disent les agriculteurs sur mon
territoire c'est bénédicte comment on va
jusqu'au point d qui est celui qui est
notre horizon et c'est à dire tout le
monde avec peut-être des circuits locaux
du bio mais moi je suis pas je suis pas
une 100% une 100% je pense pas que tout
doit être en bio je pense qu'il faut
qu'on accompagne les acteurs sur le même
donc et donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire c'est on a eu
un peu nan finalement on a une écologie
radicale versus ceux qui seraient pas
écolo en or alors justement il faut
qu'on soit entre les deux et que aux
journaleux en soit dans l'accompagnement
l'explication mais les solutions ne sont
pas radical et pardon mais enfin soyons
pragmatiques il ya une politique
agricole commune qui alimente toujours
plus le conventionnel vous par les
circuits courts vous parler
d'agriculture bio ce gouvernement a
rogné sur les aides au maintien dans
l'agriculture biologique voilà c'est la
vérité nous europarlementaires je pense
notamment yannick jadot et benoît biteau
se bat pour réorienter la politique
agricole commune qui on trouve en face
le gouvernement pour que rien
donc c'est s'agit pas d'être radical
s'agit des pragmatiques et dont les
éleveurs à se passer de ces pratiques à
l'ol jean bizet il s'intéresse aussi à
la transition écologique mais il a des
idées pour la financer effectivement
c'est une première question que je peux
vous poser monsieur le président vous
parlez beaucoup
enfin surtout vos prédécesseurs puisque
vous ne vous a pas encore entendu de la
banque européenne de l'environnement
or le problème c'est qu'elles existent
déjà à mon avis qui est la banque
européenne d'investissement vi présidé
par ambroise fayolle et qui est le bras
financier armés entre guillemets de la
commission européenne donc j'aimerais
savoir quelle est votre approche en la
matière parce que il va falloir au
travers du green deal c'est 200 300
milliards d'euros qu'il va falloir
financer tous les ans niveau européen
dans ce futur cadre financier
pluriannuel alors la transition
écologique pour la transition alors je
remercie ça c'est une très bonne heure
alors on est d'accord la vie que la
droite se seraient les députés en train
tout à fait la tradition écolo à votre
question la transition écologique
nécessite des investissements et créer
des emplois
les énergies renouvelables la rénovation
thermique dont je parle beaucoup mais ça
permet de se chauffer c'est une question
de pouvoir de vivre ça nécessite des
investissements qu'on peut chiffrer en
dizaines de milliards d'euros
on a mis depuis six ans 100 milliards
d'euros au niveau français sur le séisme
moi j'attends toujours qu'on me dise
combien d'emplois sacré on sait pas donc
pour l'accès des 100 milliards d'euros
sans contrepartie sociale ni
environnementale
ça c'est facile et c'est comme ça et il
ya personne canalise et après on nous
dit les 10 milliards d'euros qui
manquent pour la rénovation thermique
c'est très compliqué à trouver où les
800 millions d'euros pour permettre aux
gens de rénover leurs fenêtres
c'est très compliqué à trouver ça
c'était en septembre dernier donc je
voudrais pas qu'on laisse penser les
gens que c'est des sommes colossales
qu'on n'a pas mais maintenant pour vous
répondre
oui on aurait grand besoin de ce green
new deal donc ce plan de relance on va
dire au niveau européen c'est en gros 1
sur les vertes de relance verte s'est
inspiré de
ce qu'avait fait roosevelt dans les
années 30 aux etats unis en gros mettre
les gens au travail améliorer le
potentiel de long terme de notamment des
vallées un peu des délaissés de
tennessee et puis une grande refonte
fiscale
mais là les utilités ans les enfants en
france et en europe puisque aujourd'hui
des emprunteurs sont prêts à nous donner
de l'argent pour nous prêter de l'argent
ces prêts si ça vient d'éditer il ya des
liquidités qu'on était tellement versés
en pure perte aux banques qu'elles ne
savent pas où atterrir c'est là c'est la
même chose il est très mobile et non là
et bien le fonctionnement de la banque
et ont même d'investissement c'est à
dire mais qu'attend t'on pour mettre cet
argent mais aujourd'hui on n'en met
également nous dit l'argent pour la
rénovation thermique on l'a pas
d'ambassadeur de 40 milliards à peu près
mais vous avez vu ce que fait
précisément la bei au niveau de
certaines régions que ce soit la région
normandie que je connais mieux que les
autres ou la région aquitaine
c'est précisément en mobilisant entre
guillemets l'argent privé qui a du mal à
circuler en étant je dirais adossés à
des fonds publics européens que l'on
injecte si je puis dire dans cet
environnement sens propre immigrés pour
faire ses réalisations mais quand vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'opposition entre les cice et la
rénovation
je dirais thermique mais il n'y a pas
d'opposition
c'est précisément au travers des sauts
technologiques et de la r&d qui est
faite large et rarement recherche et
développement grâce précisément au cic
eux que l'on peut mieux demain
précisément faire de la rénovation
thermique mais moi il le fera je dirais
pas à l'ancienne si je puis me permets
moi j'aimerais vous croire sauf que les
milliards d'euros qui sont déversés en c
est ce qui me dit que ça va sur la r&d
on va des fois même la r&d pour auchan
ça veut dire des supermarchés sans
salarié donc bonjour la recherche et
développement excusez moi ça veut dire
que nos impôts
les baisses d'impôts les cadeaux fiscaux
finances quasiment la destruction
d'emplois
donc moi si vous me disiez on met de
l'argent sur la table et on contrôle on
vérifie que ça va véritablement à la
recherche un développeur demandé aux
chefs d'entreprise qui précisément
dépose les dossiers et vous
emplissent les dossiers sur ce plan là
vous confondez avec le crédit impôt
recherche et même là il y aurait
beaucoup à dire parce que sur le crédit
impôt compétitivité emploi
je suis désolé les fournisseurs vous
disent les gros nous rackettent c'est à
dire que les gros les grosses
entreprises calcul le cic eux qui
reçoivent les petits c'est pas moi
qu'ils amendent ans la cour des comptes
seuls les petits leurs fournisseurs et
10 puisque tu as 15 salariés que tu vas
toucher sans lui c est ce tu me fais
autant de rabais et donc ça remonte bien
on va en réponse à ces nouvelles infos
ce n'est pas faute bien merci d'accord
sur le constat est donc père arrêtons
avec ce séisme
pérol non mais c'est pas des méthodes et
contre parole ce n'est pas le débat on
va avancer contrôle au savourer entre
partis de pérols en terminale bep pérol
vous souhaitiez poser une autre question
cette fois peut-être sur la fiscalité
écologique et la transition est ce qu'il
ya des définitions différentes ou pas
alors peut-être oui puisqu'on est sur le
financement et le budgétaire j'aimerais
connaître quelle est votre vision de la
fiscalité écologique en fait aujourd'hui
à plusieurs visions on peut être sûr une
vision verdissement de la fiscalité de
manière générale d'ailleurs la
convention citoyenne pour le climat je
crois souhaitée par tous souhaité avant
tout repas le président l'a public mais
par tous propose je crois plutôt le
verdissement puisqu'elle propose une tva
qui serait finalement dans lequel on
intégrait rangs nantais grevé par un
parent apparaît par exemple la dimension
environnementale
et puis il ya aussi une autre vision qui
pourrait être celle de créer de nouveau
une nouvelle fiscalité écologique de
nouvelles taxes alors on a on a beaucoup
débattu de la contribution climat
énergie dite taxe carbone à la fin de
l'année dernière et donc j'aimerais
j'aimerais savoir un peu comment vous
positionner par rapport à ça et puis je
crois qu'il ya une dimension mais
extrêmement importantes tant du point de
vue de la fiscalité aussi que 10
financement c'est le désinvestissement
aussi de tout ce qui est carbonées et là
j'aimerais avoir créé en son temps mais
il ya le sujet justement fiscalité de
dans leurs dépenses fiscales
défavorables à l'environnement c'est
tout
finalement les exonérations de taxes sur
les icpe et j'aimerai connaitre
finalement si vous vous étiez
parlementaire telles méthodes vous
appliqueriez aujourd'hui je travaille
sur ces sujets là il faut travailler ce
secteur par secteur comment ce visage il
voilà vous avez la question des visas
qui est certain c'est que toutes les
recettes qui viennent de la fiscalité
écolo doivent être intégralement
reversés aux personnes vulnérables
dépendant de la voiture par exemple ou
investi dans des infrastructures de
transport collectif qui permet de s'en
passer
c'est tout le problème de c'était
l'étincelle de la question des gilet
jaune
vous aviez une eau sur le carburant le
diesel mais le kérosène on va dire le
carburant des riches
le kérosène de l'avion ou le fioul lourd
des navires qui est extrêmement polluant
truc toxiques même pour les populations
riveraines n'étaient pas taxées et les
gens avaient le sentiment et on peut pas
leur donner tort que cet argent ce
n'était pas pour financer dé la
transition mais c'était en gros pour
combler les trous des cadeaux fiscaux
faits aux plus riches et donc là vous
avez la fiscalité écolo j'ai envie de
dire qui prend la balle perdue parce
qu'il ya un ressentiment à l'égard de
l'impôt il ya un ressentiment et un
sentiment de de la demande et gilet
jaune c'était que les petits pays petits
que les gros pays oui mais les augmenter
vous feriez quoi venez donc nous un peu
avec ce qu'ont proposé sur la taxe poids
lourds c'est que l'intégralité des
recettes collectées vont aux personnes
vulnérables et et des taxes et bien par
exemple sur le kérosène sur le diesel
sur le 40 pour le coup vous le savez
très bien qu'il y ait une dimension
européenne ça relève d'accord
international maritime c'est pareil
alors ça relève d'un convention de
chicago effectivement de 1944 il y avait
assez peu d'avions et donc depuis lors
le carburant est pas taxés au niveau
international mais rien n'interdit de le
faire sur la france j'ai jamais entendu
parler de la rue d'anjou et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises quand
il était interdit de le faire au niveau
européen et j'ai entendu du croit le
ministre hollandais le proposait la
belgique a dit je fais et j'ai pas
entendu un son est aujourd'hui en train
de aussi mené des négociations pour
faire en sorte que sur le kérosène et
par seconde
des négociations sont ouvertes et la
france poussé au niveau de l'effort soit
parfait pour faire la chose à ce que
finalement on crée des coalitions pour
faire en sorte que ce kérosène
effectivement qui crée une injustice
énorme entre les français puisque
effectivement les ménages payent la taxe
carbone et d'autres ne paierez pas et ça
effectivement j'ai même des ripailles
deux fois parce que par an pour
l'aéroport de nîmes
ça coûte 3 millions aux collectivités
locales de faire l'aéroport de nîmes
alors qu'il ya un aéroport à côté à
montpellier est ce que vous trouvez
normal que les gens qui habitent à nîmes
qui prennent pas forcément beaucoup
l'avion il paye ses 3 millions d'euros
et en plus l'exemption sur le kérosène
et désolé mais pourquoi se jeter sur le
kérosène
parce que ça pollue mais parce que c'est
le carburant de l'avion alors qu'on
pourrait avantager le train le coût
d'émission de co2 par un passager dans
un avion un passager ces 3 litres aux
100 km je vais les émissions de co2 de
la filière aéronautique je dirais
mondiale ces 3 % comparé à 4 % de la
gestion du big data
donc arrêtons d'avoir je dirais des
raisonnements trop réducteur c'est pas
réducteur mais si on vous dit sur un
paris nice - paris montpellier on
désavantage l'avion j'ai pas dit comment
l'interdisait moi je serais pour
l'interdire mais là j'étais juste à le
désavantager et on avantage le train est
ce que vous voyez les prix pour un paris
montpellier moqué la famille par là bas
c'est c'est ridicule donc vous avez
maintenant l'avion qui est moins cher
que le train sur une distance de quatre
heures nous disons des avantages dans
l'avion avantage on le train bien bien
alors oui aussi parler du nucléaire jean
bizet oui je trouve qu'il y a une
certaine hypocrisie en france et
notamment d' des milieux écologistes de
ne pas vouloir parler du nucléaire de le
d'en parler d'une façon particulièrement
négative
or quand on regarde si je puis dire le
mix énergétique nationale il est
particulièrement vertueux grâce au
nucléaire
nous je dirais et mettons trois fois
moins de co2 qu'un allemand et si
j'ajoute également un autre point il n'y
aurait pas je dirais de développement
ont si je dirais important même si vous
trouvez que ça ne va pas assez vite des
énergies renouvelables si nous n'avions
pas précisément un socle qui est celui
de l'énergie nucléaire donc moi je suis
un adepte de l'énergie nucléaire parce
que si je puis dire c'est au niveau de
l'environnement l'énergie la plus
vertueuse
alors est ce que vous craignez pas que
le mur l'investissement du nucléaire
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas le
financer inc les 'points 20 milliards
buron l'enfouissement des déchets on
sait pas si ces 30 ou 50 ou peut-être
demain 80 la rénovation des centrales
on est sur 50 à 100 et on parle même pas
comment les démantèlent et je peux faire
et j'espère qu'on arrêtera anglais merci
effectivement ça fait 10 12 ça edf s'est
pas le financer d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
que thomas piquemal qui est pas un écolo
c'était le directeur financier d'edf
avait démissionné en disant inc les
punks les 20 milliards là qui produisent
de l'énergie à 109 euros alors que le
photovoltaïque est à 30 ou 40
il dit ça ça verra pas le jour et c'est
la mort d'edf aujourd'hui des syndicats
qui portait pas forcément les écolos
dans leur coeur quand on disait il faut
acter maintenant la sortie dans 20 ans
on veut dire les autres à la raison
non les syndicats du nucléaire mais à
jeudi puisqu'ils sont en majorité oui
voilà mais est bien aujourd'hui nous
disent on est en train de tuer edf est
d'ailleurs le gouvernement prépare la
privatisation des bénéfices
et puis la socialisation des pertes et
enfin comme toujours quoi le nucléaire
ah c'est fini il faut envisager la suite
je suis je suis arrivé au fond on est en
train de sa coûte cher ça coûte très
cher pour les bonnes raisons et c'est
que le photovoltaïque
absolument il est au lien mais
absolument mais pourquoi tout simplement
parce que les exigences
je dirais sécuritaire depuis fukushima
sont ce qu'elles sont deuxièmement nous
ne savons plus au bout de 50 en un
demi-siècle fabriquer des centrales
puisque nous n'arrêtons très complet
mais si nous arrêtons le nucléaire vous
savez très bien que nous ne pouvons pas
je dirais alimenter les foyers les u
travail en entreprise avec simplement le
le renouvelable
le produit et le danemark l'allemagne
parviennent de temps en temps mais parce
que également si vous voulez vous avez
des interconnexions l'allemagne
attendait avec lequel ci voulant
franco-allemand on peut être que je
dirais particulièrement intéressé de
voir le couple franco-allemand depuis x
années faire évoluer l'europe
l'allemagne n'est pas je dirais
intellectuellement honnête sur le sujet
parce que si elle n'avait pas des
voisins qui fournissent de l'énergie
nucléaire pour en période je dirais que
dans le cas en l'occurrence du soleil
non ça marche dans les deux sens
répondre sans perdre les deux dirigeants
sûrement plus rater le virage c'est à
dire que même si c'était pas pour faire
plaisir aux écologistes mais uniquement
dans l'intérêt bien compris d'une
filière d'excellence travailler sur le
démantèlement et développer les énergies
renouvelables
on est à la bourre on est en train de
rater le virage du xxième siècle et donc
si mes arguments ne vous convainquent
pas regarder les chiffres
il ya plus d'emplois dans les énergies
renouvelables et le photovoltaïque et
l'éolien sera moins cher si vous voulez
pas entendre l'argument par exemple des
déchets nucléaires
quand ça dure 50 millions c'est plus que
le temps de l'invention de la langue sur
le continent européen et où vous aviez
c'est complètement là c'est une autre
figure est ce qu a regarder si cet
argument ne vous ne portent pas je vous
ai d'arguments ne portent pas auprès de
vous entendez l'argument économique il
ya plus d'emplois et ça fournit une
énergie moins chère
allons-y est-ce qu'on dise pas dans ce
débat aussi que le nucléaire est une
énergie qui est permanente tandis que
nrj on a fondé ce sont des énergies
intermittentes aujourd'hui le vrai sujet
c'est que peut-être avant de décider
trajectoire on sort totalement nucléaire
aussi c'est d'investir et c'est ce que
fait la france notamment aussi avec la
libye sur les batteries mais il faut
qu'on arrive à développer des mécanismes
de stockage parce qu'aujourd'hui avec
les énergies renouvelables éolien
photovoltaïque a juste
l'hydroélectricité aujourd'hui qui nous
permet d'avoir une énergie qui soit
finalement elle permanente mais je crois
que c'est important de le mettre dans le
débat aussi parce que se sentant pas en
français c'est pas parce qu'on aura 100%
d'énergies renouvelables qu'on permettra
de subvenir aux besoins en tout cas si
on est dans la situation technologique à
tes gars mais il ya des pays qui
parviennent de plus en plus costa rica
danemark portugal
mais l'enjeu quand vous discutez des
industriels ils ont ils ont besoin d'une
stabilité
donc quand on dit on va reporter la
décision eh bien ils n'investissent pas
et donc on est en train de rater le
virage c'est pour ça que nous disons
l'investissement dans nucléaire et
concurrent de l'investissement dans les
énergies renouvelables on peut pas faire
les deux en même un peu trop et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on veut c'est pour ça
qu'on en veut à françois hollande
parce que dans sa fameuse loi de
transition énergétique c'était 2025
il a rien fait et du coup qu'est ce
qu'on fait on reporte à 2035
et que font les industriels y lisons la
droite continuer à leurs actes et
aujourd'hui
je voulais jouer dans votre sens acté
aujourd'hui la sortie dans 15 20 25 ans
au fur et à mesure de l'obsolescence des
programmes des centrales elles vont pas
durer toute la vie
et bien c'est le moyen d'investir
pendant ce temps là sur la montée en
charge des renouvelables
mais sait on acte pas la fin et non le
fait pas férole voulais vous poser une
question aussi sur votre conception un
peu de transition écologique la
transition écologique juste parce que
c'est vrai qu'on en parle beaucoup alors
vous avez commencé un petit peu en
parlais tout à l'heure quand vous a
parlé de redistribution c'est à dire que
si demain on revenait à la contribution
climat énergie je pense que projet
européen nous permettra de répondre et
c'est très bien que ce soit pris au
niveau l'union européenne parce que
c'est là où elles sujet une taxe carbone
aux frontières
néanmoins aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
de transition écologique juste
effectivement est-ce que ça ce
finalement traduit uniquement par une
redistribution auprès des plus précaires
auprès des français les plus fragiles
est ce que vous mettez dedans aussi
finalement encore une fois cette notion
de transition aujourd'hui on n'arrive
pas à finalement est ce que la notion de
coût dans cette transition
comment vous l'abordez comment vous la
mettez en positionnement par rapport aux
autres investissements au niveau
international comme à l'intérieur d'un
pays ce sont les plus riches qui sont
pour aller vite responsables du
dérèglement climatique et les plus
vulnérables qui en sont les premières
victimes
voilà c'est à dire que quand vous avez
de la pollution quand vous avez des
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
ce sont les plus vulnérables les plus
pauvres typiquement quand il ya un
problème de canicule les plus riches
peuvent s'échapper où on l'a les
reconditionner et les plus pauvres par
exemple les plus seniors sont demandés
dans des appartements où il crève de
chaud donc ne pas faire la transition
c'est de l'injustice oui c'est pour ça
que c'est intrinsèquement liés et donc
faire la transition
c'est une question de redistribution et
c'est pour ça que dans le green dans le
new deal ou dans le new deal de
roosevelt
il y avait cette question de la d
investissement qui bénéficie d'abord aux
chômeurs donc aux plus vulnérables et
une profonde redistribution fiscale et
je reproche à votre gouvernement de
faire ni l'un ni l'autre une kenner
question de jean visé à propos de
l'agriculture et de l'environnement
parce que vous êtes souvent accusé
d'aghrib aching notamment le résultat
effectivement
les écologistes si vous voulez concours
à cette agro machine peut-être à votre
corps défendant
mais le résultat il essuie là j'aimerais
savoir quelle est l'harmonisation
comment vous voyez l'articulation entre
environnement et agriculture ne me
rendais pas ne me répondez pas
uniquement circuits courts ou bio si
vous laissez un peu trop court moi je
crois que ceux qui prétendent défendre
les agriculteurs en les enfermant dans
le système actuel ne sont pas leurs
alliés et que ce n'est pas suffisant
d'aller au salon de l'agriculture et de
flatter les vaches et puis dire voilà ce
qui nous nourrit c'est super et le
lendemain de les abandonner dans les
mains des banques est dans les mains des
centrales d'achat c'est en gros ce qu'on
fait la droite et le parti socialiste
depuis des décennies entre parenthèses
comme les finances ou l'alcool fnsea
dénoncent la grille bashing vous sentez
visé vous sentez concernés non non sûr
que non nous ne vous sentez pas concéder
bien sûr que non mais ils ont tort je
pense on va peut-être en discuter et
j'espère que il tant ils répondront à la
main content parce que nous nous disons
nous on est là et bien sûr sous les
disques des soucis aux normes sommes les
meilleurs et man nous sommes leur
meilleure alliée concrètes un
agriculteur passent au bio
sa rémunération augmente quand il reste
dans le circuit conventionnel vous allez
un tiers seulement des régulateurs qui
peuvent se rémunérer donc un moment
comment on fait nous le disons aide à la
transition est de maintien vous allait
supprimer les halles au maintien ce cic
à 20 milliards si on n'en consacraient
seulement 10%
dix incendies dans l'aide aux
agriculteurs internationales ont dit
europe écologie a consacré une vraie
aide aux agriculteurs qui ont réorienté
la politique les rendre moins dépendant
concerne nous nous sommes contre le ceta
contre les traités qui a alors lancé que
leur font une concurrence qui croyais à
dieu nous sommes la meilleure zèbre ou
pourquoi les produits biologiques les
produits de l'agriculture biologique
sont vendues plus cher 20 30 parfois les
enfants dans les entreprises se font une
marche dessus
d'une parce que c'est utile ce n'est que
le conventionnel non messieurs a lancé
ça surtout parce que c'est une niche
or si vous grossissez si je puis dire
cette frange de l'agriculture biologique
ancenis vous en ferez pardon
renseignez-vous ses péniches discuter
avec quelqu'un du super u je l'alsace
quartier très populaire c'est pas une
niche c'est pas les riches
bien sûr 20 30% plus cher que les
produits conventionnels qui eux et bien
non les romains réalité objective
notre objectif c'est que tout le monde
puisse manger bio parce que ça ne doit
pas être réservé aux jeunes riches et
que les agriculteurs puissent surnom
n'est pas suffisamment de luxure vivre
et bien travaillons aussi bien et bien
voilà l'invitation est lancée général
qu'un qui a une main tendue à la fnsea
on va appeler christiane lambert pour
savoir ce qu'elle en pense merci gens
visés merci bénédicte pétrole d'être
venu sur ce plateau
deux auditions publiques et intervient
la dernière
[Musique]
la dernière partie ces cartes blanches
ail frère qui a tout écouter vous avez
écouté attentivement et il ya
certainement encore des choses à mendive
bonsoir francis bonsoir julien billot je
vous appelle pas président un secrétaire
national
mais blasé c'était très intéressant je
pouvais et c'est pas à prendre le
flatteur parce que pour une fois on
envisage l'écologie avec un militant de
l'écologie ou un partisan de l'écologie
passe sous l'angle simplement il faut
faire propre sous l'angle économique
avec l'écologie peut créer des emplois
l'écologie peut booster la croissance
donc j'en ai lu nan alors j'en déduis
justement ma question était là dans
l'écologie vient vivre voulait vivre
d'accord vous n'êtes pas un apôtre de la
décroissance
en fait c'est un mot pour interroger la
croissance et la décroissance ciblées
dans les divers en fait si vous appelez
président moi je veux moins d' amazon et
plus de libraires je veux moins de
auchan et plus de centres de commerce de
proximité
donc si vous si vous voulez aller là
dedans une croissance des activités
utiles et une décroissance des activités
néfastes voire une interdiction accord
donc l'enjeu c'est tout danger d'un
retour à l'âge de pierre même nom mérite
et non l'âge de pierre weiss et
continuer avec le nucléaire parce que
quand les centrales s'arrête on sait
plus faire d'accord donc attendez
l'enjeu c'est de questionner la finalité
l'économie depuis
depuis je suis né depuis
depuis bien avant ma naissance
d'ailleurs depuis les trente glorieuses
on dit il faut qu'on produise quoiqu'il
quoi qu'il en coûte
quelles que soient les panneaux y semant
des salariés et quel que soit l'impact
pour la planète
là nous disons questionnement la
finalité de l'économie est-ce que
produire du plastique toujours plus est
une bonne chose
est ce que le trading à haute fréquence
par exemple sans aucun rapport avec
l'économie réelle
un sens nous disons non et donc on
questionne ses activités alors je dis
est ce que le cic est toujours plus
d'argent sans contrepartie nous disons
non à l'est par contre par contre donner
de l'argent vous terrorise entrepreneur
il a terminé c'est facile il est très
bien réussir à vous permettre de
continuer je viens bio vous êtes d'une
la figure montante une des figures
montantes de l'écologie en france il ya
un autre personnage qui jaillit pendant
qu'ils aient connue depuis quelques
temps mais qu'ils avaient quand même
jaillissent et des qui s'appelle yannick
jadot
est-ce que vous et moi j'ai dit oui
voilà est-ce que vous êtes sur la même
ligne que lui est ce que vous avez là
vous défendez la même écologie est ce
que vous êtes d'accord sur tout où
l'essentiel
ah bah oui oui cent oui je cherche je
vois pas tellement de sujets sur lequel
on sera en désaccord nous nous sommes
sur l'affirmation de l'écologie et le
dialogue avec les autres forces d'accord
l'enjeu c'est de proposer au pays une
alternative heureuse alors nous ne
voulons pas être contraint de rejouer le
match
macron le pen d'autant plus que cette
fois-ci macron pourrait le perdre donc
un crew se voulait rempart contre le
front national
il devient marché pieds notre
responsabilité est la responsabilité d'y
annick en particulier qui arrivait en
tête le 26 mai au soir c'est de proposer
bien une alternative heureuse pour le
pays d'accord c'est bien justement si ce
travail de gagner en 2022 appeler une
question qui est fondamentale
yannick jadot a fait des tribunes a
beaucoup parlé après son beau score aux
élections européennes il a dit il a fait
comprendre que bon on ne parlait plus de
gauche et de droite il fallait parler
d'écologie on écologie intelligente
entre guillemets et qu'il fallait avoir
une posture qui consistait à gagner des
élections
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
est ce que l'écologie n'est plus
nécessairement thèmes qu'on l'entendait
ici
beaucoup dans notre pays de gauche c'est
ce que je vous disais de l'affirmation
de l'écologie répond affirmation
l'écologie je pense que ces autres aux
autres forcent maintenant de se
positionner nous disons l'écologie et le
cadre de référence de ce siècle qui
vient c'est l'enjeu majeur
ouais les autres forces doivent se
positionner et donc à partir de là à
partir de là c'est les autres forces
mais celle qui se considère comme non
productiviste qui sont humanistes qui
sont progressistes qui sont démocrates
oui bien sûr moi je suis de gauche est
devenu écologiste mais je viens de la
gauche si vous voulez oui je porte des
des valeurs dans lequel je pense
beaucoup de gens de gauche bien sûr se
reconnaîtrait la domination
nous n'avons pas envie et dans ce que
nous jeudi les écologistes mais je pense
que je peux parler pour yannick nous
n'avons pas envie de demander un
bréviaire un passeport aux personnes qui
aujourd'hui se disent tiens avant c'est
vrai l'écologie qu'est ce que c'est la
priorité
mais donc il apprend que je prends deux
exemples de courage et de 70 ans qui
toute sa vie a voté à droite est saisie
mince l'écologie est ce qu'on veut à la
barre et non non et la jeune tête de
liste qu'à 24 ou 25 ans par dans pauline
à boulogne pauline rapilly ferniot 24 ou
25 ans est ce qu'on va lui parler de la
chute du mur du programme commun même de
la gauche plurielle elle est écologiste
d'accord donc il a raison quand ils
cotisent il faut gagner des élections
nous avons raison quand nous disons que
nous voulons gagner des vies d'accord il
ya des élections municipales ça tombe
bien dans quatre mois
il ya des situations très variables
d'une ville à l'autre
est-ce que vous pouvez vous alliez à des
forces de gauche est-ce que vous pouvez
vous alliez à des forces de droite quand
basse et la condition de notre victoire
ne sont a dit au niveau national parce
que chez nous c'est les gens qui votent
ça peut surprendre mais c'est comme ça
il s'est au niveau local que se prennent
les décisions
le cadrage national c'est projet
écologiste est incompatible avec les
droite la droite libérale donc les
droites libérales dans marge
rassemblement national l'extrême droite
voilà
m là c'est ça c'est la droite libérale
qui fait à droite parce qu'elle est
productiviste oui c'est le séisme il
sans christ donc mais c'est le séisme
s'est produit liste du moment que ça se
pose là c'est françois hollande est
conseillé par emmanuel modem vous prenez
avec vous pas non a priori non il est
allié dans marche pour sembler beaucoup
d'allers-retours entre les verts et le
modem 1 quelques exemples quand même
enfin moi en tout cas l'affirmation de
l'écologie et ceux qui se retrouvent
celles et ceux qui se retrouvent dans
l'affirmation de l'écologie
ouais bien sûr les bienvenues pour
construire un abri ok on ouvre les bras
mais par la droite
dicaprio ils ont à l'écologie
raccompagner les cas graves s'ils
voulaient parce que la droite c'est
permettre à tout le monde y compris à
total de faire son business et nous nous
disons mais c'est ce que je disais sur
questionner la finalité de l'économie
il ya des activités que nous voulons
décourager vous êtes notamment du manque
total et la déforestation est donc
clairement à gauche quoi clairement
écologistes oui vous allez vous y faire
vous essayez de ripoliner la chose non
je crois que c'est donc il arrive et non
pardon excusez moi et c'est vraiment
avec tout le respect que je vous dois
c'est vous qui pensent avait du mal à
accepter que il ya un nouveau paradigme
c'est l'écologie c'est ce qu'on va
proposer en 2022 et ça commence par les
municipales à paris
comment ça se passe à paris vous faites
une liste autonome en fait une liste
oui mais vous faites une liste mais vous
avez sûrement des annales si elle fait
une liste autonome
je ne lis pas je les faisais les blues
n'ont fait ni tripoli mais je vais poser
la tension ne savait pas qui est ce que
de toute manière quoi qu'il arrive si
jamais vous n'êtes pas au deuxième tour
eh bien vous appeler à voter pour madame
hidalgo
mais déjà pour les lits seront m seront
en tête dans bon nombre c'est que à
paris ça se déroule par arrondissement
et nous serons en tête dans certains
arrondissements j'espère le 20e et
autres red bull le 10e arrondissement
avec sylvain fo et d'autres je peux en
citer mon temps au troisième et donc
nous espérons quand il faut construire
un groupe qui puisse peser véritablement
dans le podium 3e tour 6 au 3e tour vous
n'êtes pas suffisamment nombreux comme
me conseiller de paris pour être mère eh
bien nous choisirons mais je pense qu'on
peut être bon et nous choisirons le
projet le plus en phase avec l'écologie
c'est à dire environnement justice
sociale démocratie je les ai bien
compris ça peut pas être plus benjamin
griveaux sera peut-être bien malgré vos
non non ça c'est un marché incertain à
fait calmes d'hidalgo ou daniel simba
d'argent agriva ça serait bien qu'il
aille à l'assemblée tan lontan vikash
dhorasoo peut-être on peut beaucoup
discuté vikash dhorasoo on ice cube
beaucoup c'est un allié autre élection
des questions parce qu'après cette
élection miss élections municipales il
ya des régionales et départementales
puis on arrive à la présidentielle ces
jeunes yannick jadot le meilleur des
candidats pour vous pour les 2022 bah
écoutez il a une stature particulière
après le le 26 mai maintenant l'enjeu -
cd municipal puis comme vous l'avez dit
des départementales et les régionales
les présidentielles sont encore loin moi
l'enjeu c'est de construire le mouvement
qui est capable de porter une
candidature à la présidence de la
république
si à l'heure du goût et bien il viendra
le temps de les désigner yannick jadot
est elle la figure c'est la largeur de
pouget pas couvrir la tête d'affiche la
figure de proue
nous verrons en temps utile comment nous
désignons le la candidate
évidemment que yannick jadot ces partis
hier brusque lauriad il ya son propre
compte
alors jamais c'est marrant parce que
j'allais dire que yannick jadot est plus
que qualifié pour le poste
alors que ségolène royal a justement
montré par deux fois qu'en tant que
ministre de l'environnement elle n'était
pas particulièrement utile pour le dire
comme ça
une dernière question il encore si oui
alors une dernière question et je
regardais yannick jadot frein bien
meilleur président qu emmanuel macron
attendait déjà sur lui ce n'est pas moi
qui vais dernière question du jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon dans la
perspective de 2022 justement propose
qu'un accord de gouvernement soient
passés avec europe écologie
m le mouvement que vous ne présidez pas
mec dont vous êtes le secrétaire
national
est ce que vous êtes intéressés et vous
est-ce que vous êtes intéressés nous
notre objectif c'est ancré l'écologie
aux municipales et derrière construire
le rassemblement ces derniers qui gagne
aux régions et donc sur la base d'un
projet écologiste écologie au sens
environnement justice sociale démocratie
cette mélenchon compatible sadc à lui de
se poser la question s'il est compatible
avec un projet centré sur l'écologie
pour gagner des régions et la présidence
vous êtes en position de force par
rapport à lui aujourd'hui
non c'est pas comme ça mais simplement
si on débat il faut qu'on se rend compte
et qu'on discute un peu projet la
question c'est quel projet pour le pays
nous voulons éviter le match retour
macron le pen parce que cette fois ci
macron pourrait le perdre
il a tellement rien fait sur
l'environnement ni sur la justice
sociale qui menace la démocratie nous
portons un projet écolo macro
environnement démocratie mais je pense
qu'il nous fait courir un risque aux
majeurs merci julien bayou de vinci la
condition publique c'est la fin de votre
audition publique pour ce soir je vous
ayez des décennies oui c'est vrai mais
bon vous avez parlé si c'est pour nous
c'est sympa merci je vais en tout cas
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur figaro live ainsi que
sur les comptes twitter de lcp assemblée
nationale et public sénat
bonne semaine merci et évidemment à
lundi prochain 19 heures
[Musique]